ich heiße riad 1980 war ich zwei jahre
alt und bereits ein ganzer kerl
damals war die welt ein nebel bevölkert
von freundlichen grüßen
was für ein hübscher kleiner alle frauen
wollten nicht im arm halten
ich war täglich nicht mehr als ein paar
stunden wach aber das reichte ich wusste
genau wie man durchs leben kam
heute ist riad sattouf 36 und immer noch
ein ganzer kerl
naja mit kleinen abstrichen dass ihm
wildfremde frauen in den arm nehmen
passiert ihm nur noch selten in meinem
buch der araber von morgen erzähle ich
die geschichte einer franco syrischen
familie die zugleich die geschichte
meiner eigenen familie und meiner
kindheit ist
ich schildere ereignisse die dem leser
unglaublich schockierend gewaltsam und
total zu realistisch erscheinen mögen
und ich zeige sie mit den augen eines
kindes für das all das total normal ist
riad vater wird nach seiner promotion in
paris dozent an der universität in
tripolis dass libyen unter gaddafi für
den jungen ein abweisender geradezu
surrealer ort getaucht in das geld der
wüste
vor dem konflikt zwischen abendland und
morgenland rettet ihn
der übergroße erscheinende vater ein
historiker mit einer schwäche für
schneidige diktator gaddafi war die
ganze zeit auf dem bildschirm ich fand
erinnert mir wie ich war er von leuten
umgeben die ihm bewunderten und an
lächelten
mein vater wollte dabei helfen die
arabische welt in dem moderne und in die
unabhängigkeit zu führen aber
gleichzeitig war er für die todesstrafe
und gegen die demokratie
wie viele aus einer generation dieser
aufgewachsen sind wie er erwartete er
dass die arabische welt sich ändern
würde
aber sie hat sich nicht geändert
zumindest nicht so wie er sich das
erhofft hatte es hat ihn wirklich
frustriert und sehr wütend gemacht von
diesem widerspruch hat sich mein vater
nie erholt von der absurdität
diktatorischer herrschaft handelt auch
riad sattouf neuer film jackie im
königreich der frau
in der fiktiven volksrepublik bühne
einer mischung aus nordkorea und einem
feministischen kalifat haben frauen die
uniform hosen an
die männer sind dazu verdammt schleier
zu tragen am herd zu stehen und heilige
pferdchen anzubieten
kaum weniger bizarre zeitz eigene
kindheit in der arabischen welt
auch in syrien klaffen ideologische
anspruch und trostlose wirklichkeit weit
auseinander
in der heimat von riad vater einem
sunnitischen dorf bei homs spürt man in
den 1980 er jahren von radikalen
islamismus noch nichts
ein hort der geborgenheit ist es dennoch
nicht
als ich mich der gruppe näherte zeigt
zwei jungen mit den fingern auf mich
yehuda bedeutete jude
das ist das erste wort im syrischen
arabisch dass ich gelernt habe
es sollte für iad nicht die letzte
verstörende erfahrung bleiben was ich in
meinem buch auch erzählen möchte ist
dass die idee als kampf der kulturen in
der wirklichkeit gar nicht existiert
sondern nur in den köpfen der menschen
das frankreich der 50er jahre ist exakt
das gleiche wie syrien in den achtzigern
das hat man nur erfolgreich verdrängt
meiner meinung nach ist das alles nicht
zu verschiedenen sondern nur eine simple
ökonomische frage riad sattouf wollte
einen comic für leute machen wie keine
comics lesen
es ist die mit seinem einfachen aber
ausdrucksstarken zeichenstil rundum
geglückt so bedrückend er den alltag
unter einem despoten die hafis al assad
auf skizziert als leser hat man das
heutige syrien im hinterkopf
die araber von morgen haben es nicht
beim krieg spielen belassen
das syrische dorf von riad kindheit
liegt heute längst in trümmern